[Applaudissements]
il y a 10 000 ans en devenant chien le
loup à domestiquer l'homme
en développant des nouveaux muscles
juste au dessus des yeux qui
n'existaient pas chez le loup le chien a
pu imiter les expressions faciales de
l'homme
vous savez ce regard attendrissant
auquel on peut pas résister
ainsi les chiens et les hommes ont pu
communiquer ils ont commencé à se
comprendre ils ont eu besoin l'un de
l'autre et leur relation est devenue
symbiotiques mutuellement bénéfique
bon il y a fort à parier que le loup
n'avait pas conscience de ce qu'il était
en train de faire il a probablement
juste à donner procédé par essai erreur
et la sélection naturelle a fait le
reste
n'empêche que aujourd'hui le résultat
est là les chiens et les hommes se
comprennent au moins en partie
cohabitent et s'entraide
pourquoi est-ce que je vous raconte tout
ça alors je suis pas au blog je suis pas
non plus éthologue l'éthologie c'est
l'étude des comportements j'ai même pas
de chien
je raconte tout ça parce que je pense
qu'il va se passer exactement la même
chose avec l'intelligence artificielle
elle ne va pas nous dominer ou nous
exterminer comme le fantasme certain non
elle a besoin de nous faire disparaître
ne serait pas très malin
elle va plutôt se rendre indispensable
faire en sorte qu'on l'aime et qu'on ne
puisse plus se passer d'elle
bon si vous trouvez que la comparaison
est un petit peu tirée par les cheveux
ou les poils
c'est peut-être que vous ne maîtrisez
pas bien les mécanismes d'apprentissage
profond de l'intelligence artificielle
pour apprendre mais évidemment des
guillemets à prendre on expose
l'intelligence artificielle à des
millions de situations pour lesquelles
on connaît déjà la réponse
et quand ça répond à la nôtre on
l'encourage
je sais pas vous mais moi ça me fait
quand même beaucoup penser à du dressage
le chien tout comme l'intelligence
artificielle n'a pas conscience de ce
que vous attendez de lui
dans le cas du chien il veut juste vous
faire plaisir ou récupérer une croquette
pour autant est-ce que le chien ça le
rend le plus intelligent si je fais un
sondage dans la salle vous avez
probablement me répondre que que non le
dressage c'est exactement le contraire
de l'intelligence
donc si l'intelligence artificielle
apprend par une forme de dressage et que
le dressage c'est pas de l'intelligence
on peut légitimement se poser la
question de savoir si l'intelligence
artificielle est intelligente
c'est une bonne question
je ne sais pas
alors c'est pas que j'ai jamais réfléchi
à la question ou que j'ai pas d'avis sur
le sujet non j'ai plein d'avis sur le
sujet mais j'arrive pas à choisir
d'un côté l'intelligence artificielle
c'est faire des choses que seuls les
humains pouvaient faire jusqu'à il n'y a
pas très longtemps
d'un autre côté ce qu'il faut être
intelligent pour écrire une lettre de
motivation ou analyser de mammographie
ça se discute
en fait c'est quoi l'intelligence
alors si votre définition de
l'intelligence c'est
ce qui fait de nous des humains
par opposition je suppose à des animaux
et par extension à des machines
alors là non évidemment l'intelligence
artificielle n'est pas intelligente
puisqu'elle n'est pas humaine
donc la seule forme d'intelligence que
l'on connaisse c'est la nôtre
mais bon c'est un peu court cette vision
anthropomorphique de l'intelligence elle
risque de nous faire passer à côté
d'autres formes d'intelligence
c'est exactement comme si vous étiez en
train de chercher des extraterrestres et
que vous étiez tellement convaincu
qu'ils ont forcément deux bras de jambes
que vous pouvez les croiser sans les
reconnaître
donc peut-être qu'il faut élargir la
déficience de l'intelligence
à la Darwin en gros l'adaptation à son
environnement ou dit autrement la
capacité à résoudre des problèmes
d'ailleurs dans les années 50 il y a un
test qui a été inventé pour détecter le
jour où les machines deviendraient
intelligentes
c'est intéressant de voir que ça a été
anticipé à ce point-là donc ça s'appelle
le test de Turing du nom de son
inventeur à la Turing
c'est assez simple vous mettez un humain
devant un clavier et un écran
l'humain pose des questions en tapant
sur le clavier l'écran lui répond et
l'humain doit décider si les réponses
proviennent d'un autre humain ou d'une
machine
si l'humain arrive à démasquer la
machine c'est selon Turing qu'elle n'est
pas intelligente
dit autrement toujours selon Turing vous
êtes intelligent si vous arrivez à créer
l'illusion que vous l'êtes
tu peux tordu ça non comme définition
et puis encore une fois on se regarde le
nombril le juge c'est toujours l'humain
et s'il existait d'autres formes
d'intelligence
vous souvenez les premiers avions qui
essayent de battre des ailes en imitant
les oiseaux bon c'est aujourd'hui que
pour voler vite et loin c'est quand même
plus prudent de pas mettre des ailes
donc peut-être qu'il existe des formes
d'intelligence
qui ne ressemblent pas à la nôtre mais
qui pour autant sont efficaces
voire supérieur
donc c'est décidé je vais me lancer
je vais trancher nous allons convenir
ensemble ce soir que
oui intelligence artificielle est
intelligente à sa façon
et alors
et alors ça change ça change tout ça
veut dire qu'elle va être capable de ne
remplacer sur des tâches cognitives des
tâches intellectuelles si vous préférez
et ça c'est très nouveau
que la technologie assiste ou remplace
des humains c'est très ancien c'est
aussi vieux que la technologie mais
c'était beaucoup des emplois peu
qualifiés c'était beaucoup à travers la
force physique et donc la mécanisation
si je mets une masseuse dans un champ
effectivement je vais remplacer une
centaine d'ouvriers agricoles mais
encore une fois c'est pas des emplois
très qualifiés je peux prendre des
exemples comme ça dans absolument tous
les secteurs si je prends je sais pas le
transport ça fait plusieurs années qu'il
n'y a plus de gardien dans les phares
qu'ils ont été remplacés par des
systèmes électroniques
la grande majorité des agents de la
circulation ont été remplacés par des
feux rouges
il y a de moins en moins de gardes
barrières en France bientôt tout se
remplacés par des passages à niveau
automatiques et le petit badge que vous
collez sur votre base brise c'est la
garantie qu'il y aura plus jamais
d'humain dans les cabines de péage
d'autoroute
donc ça c'est pas du tout nouveau ce qui
est très nouveau c'est qu'avec
l'intelligence artificielle on va
remplacer des emplois qualifiés des
emplois de pilotes de juge de médecins
remplacer ou changer radicalement la
nature du métier ce qui revient au même
on garde le même nom mais c'est plus le
même métier
alors soit peut-être que vous êtes
horrifié par l'idée de vous faire
soigner par une machine
mais bon écoutez ces deux scénarios
numéro 1 un désert médical 24 heures
d'attente aux urgences pour être examiné
par un interne par définition
inexpérimentée qui éventuellement ne
parle pas la même langue que vous et n'a
pas dormi depuis 36 heures
scénario numéro 2 une machine toujours
reposée à votre disposition qui a accès
à l'intégralité des diagnostics de
toutes les maladies connues y compris
les plus rares et tous les traitements
associés
je sais pas vous mais moi je choisis la
machine
alors d'accord peut-être que ça en dit
plus sur mon rapport à la technologie
que sur les progrès de l'intelligence
artificielle
il se trouve que j'ai confiance en la
technologie
vraisemblablement pour deux raisons déjà
je sais comment ça fonctionne on a
toujours moins peur de ce qu'on connaît
et puis je suis un optimiste
à ce propos alors c'est un aparté mais
j'ai jamais bien compris les pessimistes
être pessimiste c'est se préparer au
pire en général le pire n'arrive pas
donc être pessimiste c'est se préparer à
être agréablement surpris ça devrait
rendre optimiste non
revenons à notre sujet donc dans 10 ans
il y aura plus de comptable il n'y aura
plus personne dans les centres d'appel
il restera une poignée de chauffeur de
taxis et de poids lourds et quelques
journalistes triés sur le volet
alors évidemment tous les métiers sont
pataugés à la même enseigne
il y aura toujours autant de coiffeurs
la motricité fine restant inaccessible
au robot
mais bon vous voyez l'idée générale les
métiers vont disparaître d'autres vont
se transformer et certains vont émerger
en gros on va jouer aux chaises
musicales il y aura de moins en moins de
chaise de moins en moins de travail
donc ça veut dire qu'à l'échelle de la
société on va devoir travailler moins
pour produire la même chose ce qui va
mécaniquement nous générer du temps
libre
alors ça non plus c'est pas nouveau la
réduction du temps de travail ça a
commencé il y a 150 ans quand on
travaillait 80 heures par semaine on est
arrivé progressivement au 35 heures
d'aujourd'hui
et même un bouquin célèbre qui parle de
la semaine des quatre heures
quatre heures un packaging
voilà
donc ça c'est pas nouveau mais pour
autant est-ce qu'une société sans
travail est possible et qu'est-ce qu'on
va bien pouvoir faire de tout ce temps
libre
est-ce que c'est possible économiquement
si les machines font tout le travail
pourquoi pas
qui fabrique les machines
d'autres machines avec des bénévoles
à propos de bénévoles peut-être que le
tissu associatif d'aujourd'hui est un
laboratoire à ciel ouvert qui préfigure
de la société de demain
vous savez comme moi que sans les
bénévoles il y aurait plus de sport en
France il y aurait presque plus de
culture
je me suis même laissé dire qu'il y
avait des gens assez dingues pour
sacrifier leur soirée et leur week-end
pour organiser des conférences
auxquelles d'autres gens viendraient
assister
c'est complètement dingue
bah non en fait c'est pas dingue ça
s'explique ça porte un nom
ça s'appelle la motivation intrinsèque
je fais quelque chose parce que j'ai
envie de le faire pas parce que j'y suis
contraint pour payer mon loyer par
exemple
dans les années 90 la Suède qui était
confrontée à une pénurie de don du sang
a décidé de le rémunérer
résultat le nombre de donneurs a chuté
ce n'est pas compris en faisant ça c'est
qu'ils ont transformé une motivation
intrinsèque le bien commun sauver des
vies en une transaction commerciale
qui intéressait beaucoup moins de monde
ils sont évidemment revenir en arrière
n'empêche que dans une société centrale
peut-être que les gens feront plus de
choses et pas moins
vous avez dit que j'étais un optimiste
bon pour autant est-ce qu'on est prêt
pour se bouleversement majeur sans
précédent
non clairement pas je pense qu'on est
mieux préparé à une invasion
d'extraterrestres quel événement de
l'intelligence artificielle
bon ok on n'est pas prêt mais est-ce
qu'au moins on se prépare
ah si si pardon j'ai failli oublier
on se prépare on va travailler deux ans
de plus
10 fois moins mais deux ans de plus
chercher l'erreur
évidemment c'est pas simple de se
préparer déjà il faut une prise de
conscience si c'est comme le
réchauffement climatique ça risque
d'arriver mais avec 30 ans de retard et
puis il faut quand même pas mal
d'imagination pour se projeter sur un
phénomène totalement inédit d'une
ampleur sans précédent
n'empêche qu'il y aurait des choses à
faire d'urgence
je pense notamment à la réforme de notre
modèle pédagogique il va plus falloir
apprendre des métiers il va falloir
apprendre à acquérir des compétences et
ce tout au long de sa vie
bon même l'optimisme que je suis c'est
que réformer l'éducation c'est tout sauf
simple
mais comme je suis aussi un pragmatique
j'ai un plan
ma stratégie est la suivante
réformer en priorité les études longues
la logique est assez simple plus vos
études sont longues plus le monde du
travail dans lequel vous allez arriver
sera différent du monde du travail que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui
donc si je reviens mon médecin de tout à
l'heure les études longues par
excellence
est-ce qu'il faut continuer à
sélectionner les étudiants en médecine
sur leur capacité de travail et leur
capacité à prendre des choses par cœur
ça paraît un peu futile quand on sait
que dans ce domaine la machine fera
toujours mieux que nous
peut-être que le médecin du futur ce
sera plutôt un traducteur entre la
technologie et le patient entre la
machine et l'humain
dans ce contexte là des capacités de
mémorisation c'est pas essentiel
et peut-être que le plus important ça
devient l'empathie
est-ce que l'empathie
c'est inné je vois pas pourquoi ça le
ferait est-ce qu'on enseigne l'empathie
pendant les études de médecine
pas que je sache
donc clairement il va falloir changer le
contenu des études mais il va aussi
falloir changer le format des études ce
sera plus j'apprends et je mets en
application lorsque je travaille mais ce
sera j'apprends toute ma vie guidé par
l'intelligence artificielle
l'intelligence artificielle qui est une
formidable opportunité de pédagogique
puisque c'est la capacité à démocratiser
le cours particulier c'est mettre un
précepteur derrière chaque élève avec un
contenu tellement riche tellement
personnalisé et tellement ludique que
l'enseignement va devenir un loisir
comme un autre
donc avec tout le temps que vous aurez
libéré l'intelligence artificielle vous
allez consommer plus de contenu éducatif
plus de contenu culturel
plus de contenu récréatif
contenu qui auront été créés ou aider à
créer par de l'intelligence artificielle
la boucle est bouclée
merci
[Applaudissements]